hey guys holding areas 15 and today I
just installed iOS 11 wait a minute hey
Siri what time is it a time yeah
why does my time say 941 on my phone I'm
super confused right now
well anyway I'm not sure what's going on
with that that's something so to start
this video off a lot of you guys were
asking me what I thought of the rock
Siri movie first of all I absolutely
loved Wayne he's incredible an amazing
actor an amazing humans all of those
things combined two plus in an Apple ad
yeah I'm freaking excited the first
thing that I'll know because I just
installed this and I haven't really got
a chance to play with it yet so this is
sort of my first reaction hey si RI is
super CD and you just say it just things
start happening oh great just started a
live video I'll watch it so long with
hey Siri being updated and being super
speedy okay stop cancelled stop cancel
she also now has a much more realistic
voice which I can say yes she does hey
Siri tell me a bedtime story in the
great green dimension there was an
iPhone and a red balloon and a picture
of adults Hammond and Cal jumping over
the third moon I'm not sure if I get the
reference you can also now type to Siri
so typing okay yes contact information
for iJustine thank you one of the
differences here is the control center
this is completely redesigned term our
brightness up to turn my flashlight on
which is very important so everything is
now on one page which is great because
I've always so annoyed that it have to
like swipe back and forth hey Siri play
me some Adele's now playing the station
Adele yes yes
there's almost updated maps they now
have indoor map you can get more details
about airport shopping mall we just kind
of interesting because there's been many
times where I'm traveling especially at
Airport I need to know what gate you
want to go to or what restaurant is
behind security and as something that
was really never possible before let's
get a specific app for that Airport
there's also new files app which is kind
of cool because there's been so many
times where I've wanted to add
attachments in mail and I can't find
that so take your phone one step closer
to making it more computer like where
you're actually able to drag and drop
file finally it also super excited about
paying people to iMessage I feel like
all of my friends are huge venmo fans
but this is going to completely change
the game I love Apple pay and I love
places that accept Apple pay I'll go to
Bloomingdale's and I'm like Yelp pleases
I just paid for my clothes now you'll be
able to do that through I'm s if my
sister buys me coffee and I just pay her
for that coffee I can just send her an
iMessage there's some new features in
notes so it will now recognize
handwriting which is interesting so
we're taking three handwritten notes in
your notepad those will now be
translated to text so these will be
searchable now let's see if we're able
to search for this and guess what it
worked
hello hi how are you it looks pretty
cool what's good I was just a little
like a long look at that like a little
lasso
I can move it all around change colors
what's new in photos live photos effects
create loops bounces and long exposures
from your life photos live photo editing
you can alter the new key photo trim and
mutual eye photos view memories one
another memory categories for more
personal and meaningful moment so let's
try out live high of it you can swipe up
to see live photo affects people in
location all gone can loop so that's
interesting
bounce
long exposure yeah that looks creepy hey
Siri take a selfie that's just that's
going to be great because also the new
camera filters which I feel like aren't
really that new they've always had these
but you can kind of put them on live
just like this by swiping what's my
favorite how vivid cool it is cool super
dramatic
check out the new app store welcome to
the all new outdoor best way to binge
Game of Thrones I need to binge Game of
Thrones it looks like they're kind of
trying to curate a little bit more and
make it seem I don't know if it feels
actually a little bit overwhelming to be
honest with you I like these selections
down here they don't have games apps and
then update like a search one thing that
I'm going to be using and implementing
in my life is do not disturb while
driving so while you're driving and your
phone is in motion it will prevent you
from being distracted by phone calls or
text messages or notifications which I'm
excited about because I use carplay a
lot so I'm constantly being notified
that something somebody posted an
Instagram or this that I like that my
notifications will be muted what I'm
driving is something that I need to
focus on and I feel like even though I
try not to text and drive if I'm in a
red light I have this instinct where I
just want to grab my phone and check and
see if I'm missing a message no no let's
not do it another thing that's maybe
really fun for games that you can now do
screen capture on your phone which is
something that I feel like Android and
Sam assignments and other phones have
had for a very long time see if we can
activate screen recording in here you
have to go to control center customize
our control ad so inside it here you can
customize with on your control center
which is pretty neat I'm going to set my
alarm
definitely Apple TV remote my note so
now I'm going to test out my screen
recording on my phone three two one so
now recording my screen now let's stop
our recordings wait
not record ah maybe screen recording
doesn't work yet because I don't think
that worked here's the screen recording
I hit it and nothing happens okay well
it looks like screen recording isn't
working so it's kind of my first
impressions of iOS 11 it still has the
iOS 10 field when we updated iOS 10 I
feel like it was a huge overhaul so 11
that we still feels familiar I'm excited
to use it and get to know it a little
bit more perhaps I will do a follow-up
but let me know if you guys have
installed the beta another any features
that you guys are looking forward to
most in iOS 11 leave those in the
comments below and I will see you guys
in the next video
[Music]